[Music]
what's the deal with airplane penis
a month ago i asked you all to name a
comedian and tell me what olympic event
they do now i'm reading the best
comments for christchurch tom segura and
joey diaz bob sledding team that thing
would be flying dude that is like with
bert tom and joey that's like over a ton
that's like over 2 000 pounds of human
flesh on that bobsled there is no chance
that you're fitting burt tom and joy
diaz in one bobsled you couldn't even
fit burt in one bobsled shane gillis
curling you know what actually shingles
would be on the curling team him and
like louis ck would be the curlers and
then instead of like whatever ball they
used to push down the ice that thing the
curling disc that's bobby lee
he would be flying down the thing
as the disc and shane gillis and lou ck
would be the ones
sweeping them down
how about that that one spot on joe
ideas for karate you gotta go with joey
karate hey [ __ ] oh it's joey karate
today you understand me
joey diaz in the shot put brian callum
water polo that makes a lot of sense to
me i could also see brian kellen doing
something weird like fencing
or like if chess is an olympic sport or
um like fast walking what is that when
they it's just like a walking race
power walking it's called it's not
called fast walking power walking brian
callan power walking
dalia would obviously be men's diving
anything more than 30 seconds and he
wouldn't do it that's so true i feel
like crystalia could do speed skating i
feel like he kind of has that like that
shape to him where he could do speed
skating like apollo ono kind of or
diving men's diving anything that you
can contort your body in a weird way
crusade could also do ski jump i think
i'll go skiing to throw my phone off the
ski lift whoa
ah
come on
julia synchronized swimming chris lee is
definitely doing an individual event but
i could see him doing something like
swimming but he's not going to be in a
team sport no way do you like getting
stolen from do you hate privacy have you
always secretly wanted a stalker if you
said yes to any of those questions then
you probably don't have a vpn but for
the rest of us there's atlas vpn a
virtual private network makes all of
your internet traffic travel through one
encrypted tunnel this way protects you
from spying public wi-fi dangers and
hides your ip address as well as all
your online activities besides
protecting all your personal information
and your data you can do a bunch of
other cool stuff with vpns like i put
mine in the uk server so i can watch
rick and morty on netflix you can access
a bunch of new shows and movies and you
can stream them even faster actually if
you do have atlas vpn another cool
feature is cheaper youtube and netflix
subscriptions as well as being able to
find and track cheaper flights on the
internet if you're using atlas vpn right
now atlas is running a huge discount if
you use the joke world link you can get
a three-year subscription for just one
dollar and 39 cents a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee 1.39 a month
that's basically free if you use the
link in the bio right now so stop raw
dog in the internet like a psychopath
and click the link in the description
you can get atlas vpn right now for 86
off will sasso curling all right so we
have four people on the curling team now
theo von for finger skating
i don't know if you meant figure skating
or if you mean the thing where you use
like a little skateboard and use your
fingers i think that he'd be great at
finger skating and terrible at figure
skating
andrew santino looks like he plays
qriket on the weekends i could see
andrew santino just like taking off a
fencing helmet for some reason or just
something really preppy gotta be honest
archery seems like the only one you have
to give rogan by default true santino
seems like the bad guy in the olympic
skiing movie also true santino seems
like he'd be the like returning gold
medalist on the german team or something
and he goes into like the ski cab and it
messes with the other team's equipment
and it's trying to like sabotage them
and the movie's like an underdog story
santino's the villain and then we have
this guy who it's like his dream to go
skiing in the olympics and he beats him
in the end by like one point
that's exactly what it is that's very
specific but i think that's exactly how
it would go for christ from time score a
hot dog eating contest championship if
it was in the olympics
i think that tim dillon would do the hot
dog eating contest the comedian with the
best chance to meddle especially gold
battle would be
tom and bert in a doubles tennis match
i'm gonna say i play tennis like i [ __ ]
quick and all over the place okay heads
up
you getting it
huh
bert's honestly the best sneaky athlete
maybe in this whole competition
obviously as the mickey mantle jean
that's the mickey mantle team for you
hey hold your applause please
ari safir looking jewish p.s i love ari
shafir so don't come at me
okay so that's ari's olympic event
looking jewish
chris stefano would be good at swimming
or water polo he looks very aerodynamic
very dutch shout out to theo i think
chris stefano looks exactly like a
gymnast like a russian or like a slavic
gymnast in fact i'm pretty sure i've
seen him in the olympics before
competing as a russian gymnast i'm
looking up russian olympic
gymnast
men
yep there he is chris is stuffing up
right there that's him
this is christos stefano that's chris
tim dillon gymnastics floor andrew
santino is my floor artist and it's
because of this video
[Music]
feeling
good feeling good
[Music]
theo might be in group sledding because
for the sport you make an exception
getting crotch to butt inside a small
ass kayak down the icy pathway to the
finish line theo van's a hard one i feel
like he'd do like ski shooting or the
thing where you ski and then you shoot
something obscure like that i could also
see him dominating women's softball theo
hitting in the like the four spot the
cleanup spot and also playing shortstop
or third base um maybe he could do like
badminton i feel like theo could bet
around a shuttle [ __ ] pretty well seems
like something he might have done in his
youth tom segura dunk contest i also
have tom segura playing basketball
joe rogan will be our entire wrestling
and weightlifting team i think joe rogan
should be the coach of our team
do the olympics have a coach do they
have a
is there a head coach for the olympics
is that just the president
so joe rogan will be the the president
of our team
job and callum couples figure skating
that was that's good theo on the
bobsledding team will be legendary
bobby lee the special olympics the lee
brothers would represent american ping
pong bobby and stevie both have said
many times they're good at ping pong
they've also said that they're good high
school wrestlers so they could either do
ping pong or wrestling but i see them
all in the bobsled i see it going bobby
stevie and then rudy jules at the front
they could call it the bobby sled
the bobby lee sled
that's the worst joke ever
brad williams 40 meter hurdles he would
be a hurdle tom scorer wrestling chris
destefano basketball crystalia pole
vaulting brian cowan chariot racing
bobby lee ping pong true burke pressure
badminton andrew schultz bowling andrew
santino archery joe rogan taekwondo if
you don't know why that's an easy bet
i'll just take your money now all right
thanks for watching make sure you check
out the instagram link in bio to get
your free joke world stickers i'll see
you guys next time yeah yeah let me help
you
oh
[Music]
you